[Music]
ninth-grade pants and 11th grade body
I'm Elle and that's my best friend Lee
oh we've been besties since the day we
were born
how have we stayed so close we have a
set of rules like rule number two never
tell anyone else our secrets or rule
number nine lee's older brother Flynn
cases stupid hot but totally off-limits
where did you get the boobs oh and rule
number 10 never ever break rule number
nine
[Music]
okay student council is expecting our
idea for the fundraiser today what Flynn
I promise absolutely not them you have
zero experience with dyes you've never
even had a boyfriend
about a ride did you car what get on
that thing like one of your makeout
girls sitting all made out with me okay
so like 95% of them make out with me why
is it from a boy
[Music]
I decided I had to see here I was
thinking I was just your brother's
annoying best friend yeah there's that
[Music]
is there something going on between you
two nobody can know at least until I
tell me
for me there was nothing more important
than following the rules button lice
step right up ladies and gentlemen you
can either follow the rules or follow
your heart to get your long
fanny hey mom don't forget we're going
out on Saturday and I invited the
Evanses do me a favor
be sweet to elf she kind of has a crush
on you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]